[Music]
every process of her body is designed
intricately we've seen many twists and
turns in the journey of the cell cycle
we started the journey from the
preparatory phase that is the interface
to finally reach our destination that is
the dividing phase can you tell me the
name of the dividing face that's right
the dividing phase of the cell cycle
that we have seen is called mitosis
during this informated tour we've
understood the complicated process of
the cell cycle effortlessly we hope the
Lucid ideas and the concepts were
crystal clear we've halted at many
phases of the cell cycle
can you name them for me that's right
the g1 s and the g2 phases were included
in the interphase prophase metaphase
anaphase and telophase worth of phases
of the karyokinesis a part of the
dividing M phase this is then followed
by cytokinesis which results in the
division of the cytoplasm let's have a
quick revision of all these phases this
cell is fully grown and has replicated
DNA and duplicated centrosomes while
entering mitosis we know this by now so
do you remember where does this
duplication take place that's the right
answer the genetic material and the
centrosomes duplicate in the interface
or the S phase to be precise and what
about the other two phases of the
interphase needless to say g1 and g2 are
growth phases which help in the
enlargement of the cell
now this full-fledged grown cell is all
set for division it enters the first
dividing face of karyokinesis that is
the nuclear division which is called the
prophase
we are familiar with the events that the
cell undergoes in this phase the
chromatin condenses to form the
classical chromosome structure having
two sister chromatids we very well know
the chromatin is nothing but the DNA
associated with the proteins so
condensation of this chromatin begins in
the prophase and what happens next
correct the centrosomes move apart and
begin releasing mitotic spindles the
nuclear membrane and the nucleolus also
start disappearing which marks the
breakdown of the nucleus after going
through these changes the cell enters
the metaphase can you tell me the most
important change occurring during this
phase that's right formation of the
equatorial plate the chromosomes align
at the equator forming the unique
metaphase plate along with this the cell
undergoes many other changes as well the
centrosomes reach the opposite poles
also the mitotic spindle attaches to the
kinetic cores of the respective sister
chromatids all these changes prepare the
cell to enter the next phase of the
karyokinesis that is the anaphase do you
remember that anaphase is the shortest
and most rapidly occurring phase in the
complete karyokinesis yes in this phase
the sister chromatids separate and begin
their migration to the opposite poles of
the cell the cell then enters the last
phase of the karyokinesis
we know this phase well it's called the
telophase cure the cell to nuclei with
daughter chromosomes are formed in this
single cell and this is possible as the
phase carries out all the tasks reverse
of what happened in the prophase
the chromosomes D condense to gain the
relaxed string like chromatin structure
and I'll be left with something else -
that's right the nuclear membrane the
nuclear membrane and the nucleolus which
disappeared during the prophase now
start reappearing so now the cell is all
set for the last phase of the mitosis
that is cytokinesis the face of
cytokinesis divides the cytoplasm of the
cell there is a formation of a cleavage
furrow in the cell membrane which
extends up to the core and this results
in the formation of two daughter cells
these two daughter cells are genetically
identical to each other in other words
they have an equal number of chromosomes
in the nucleus with this we come to an
end with the concept of mitosis to learn
some more interesting content related to
cell biology do not forget to subscribe
to our channel happy learning
[Music]